is thor 11 thunder chris hemsworth's
marvel swan song or will he live to
bring the hammer down once again and
which comics should you read to get
hyped for the newest mcu installment for
all of this and more you'll want to
watch this before you see thor love and
thunder
in the universe where coven 19 never
happened we would have already seen thor
11 thunder by now at 2019 san diego
comic con kevin feige revealed during
the marvel studios panel that the fourth
thor film would premiere on november 5th
2021 thanks to delays from the pandemic
that date ended up going to eternals
thor 11 thunder was pushed back multiple
times first of february 18 2022 shortly
after that switch the hollywood reporter
revealed that the movie was bumping up
one week earlier to february 11th but
marvel studios wasn't done yet according
to variety thor 11 thunder was moved to
may 6 the eventual release date of
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness before finally landing on july
8th this date is as set in stone as it
ever will be so mark your calendars for
the second friday of july
as if there were any doubts chris
hemsworth is returning in thor love and
thunder to play the titular hero this
marks the aussie's ninth mcu film
appearance which includes his small
cameo and dr strange while that's a
whopping amount of mcu flicks it still
puts him behind stan lee with 22 samuel
l jackson and chris evans with 11 and
robert downey jr with 10 for the most
mcu movie appearances if hemsworth is to
be taken at his word thor love and
thunder will not be his retirement movie
in an interview with l men the actor
joked that his character is far too
young for him to consider leaving the
mcu are you crazy i'm not going into any
retirement period thor is far too young
for that he's only 1500 years old it is
definitely not a film that i say goodbye
to this brand at least i hope so we
don't think anyone would be disappointed
to have hemsworth stick around in the
mcu for as long as possible
while chris hemsworth's return and thor
love and thunder is to be expected the
announcement that natalie portman would
be returning to the mcu in the film was
more of a shock the news of the
actress's return came during the marvel
studios panel at san diego comic con in
2019 while on stage director taika
waititi introduced portman to the hall h
crowd saying that she was the only
person who could play the female thor
and thor love and thunder portman's last
mcu appearance came in avengers end game
although she never actually showed up to
the set during the production of that
movie for her appearance there old
footage of jane foster was recycled from
thor the dark world that movie thor's
first sequel marks the last time portman
filmed for marvel studios as she did not
appear in thor ragnarok her absence in
that film is briefly explained in an
offhand reference sorry to hear that
jane dumped you
she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her some mutual dumping variety
reported the off-screen reason was that
portman was disappointed with thor the
dark world and less than happy when
original director patty jenkins left the
project regardless the past is the past
and presumably money talks regardless of
how they got her there portman is back
and better than ever in thor love and
thunder
thor love and thunder will be tessa
thompson's third go-round as valkyrie
after debuting in thor ragnarok and
fighting at the battle of earth and
avengers end king the last we saw of
valkyrie was after thanos was defeated
in the fourth avengers film she says
goodbye to thor who informally declares
her the new king of asgard at the marvel
studios panel at san diego comic con in
2019 thompson revealed that one of
valkyrie's first orders of business
would be to find her queen this makes
valkyrie's return in thor love and
thunder all the more important thompson
noted her excitement about this plot
point when catching up with the rap
earlier this year the actor said we talk
so much about representation and
obviously in terms of the lbgtqia
community there's still so much work to
be done unfortunately there's not a lot
of time invested in love stories and
marvel movies in general i think that
will be a little different on the new
thor which is exciting
in january 2020 collider reported
christian bale was in talks to join thor
love and thunder 11 months later marvel
studios confirmed on twitter that the
academy award winner would be portraying
the villainous comic character gore the
godbutcher the actor has stayed silent
on his role in the upcoming film which
is only heightened the mystery of his
character taiko ytt had some interesting
comments regarding bale's gore however
he told the associated press in my
humble opinion we have probably the best
villain that marvel's ever had in
christian bale while the news of bale
joining an mcu project might have seemed
shocking to some fans the actor's resume
proves he won't shy away from a
superhero flick the actor famously
played batman and christopher nolan's
highly praised dark knight trilogy from
2005 to 2012. bale was lauded for his
portrayal of the caped crusader and
bruce wayne it's not who i am underneath
but what i do
that defines me thor love and thunder
will show us bail on the opposite side
of the superhero spectrum playing one
heck of a baddie
specific plot points of thor love and
thunder are being kept under wraps but
we can make some educated guesses about
what might happen in the film based on
the marvel comics lore gore first
debuted in 2012's thor god of thunder
number 2 making him a relatively new
character considering thor was created
in 1962 gore had it rough he grew up on
a nameless planet in deplorable
conditions and was told his whole life
that the gods would provide for him but
they never did everyone close to gore
dies tragically including his parents
partner and children after living in
such devastation he assumes that there's
no such thing as gods and gives up on
the idea one day he comes across two of
them battling when they land on his
planet knowing they're real he makes it
his mission to destroy every last one of
them he successfully kills many and
battles thor on several occasions but
this is where it gets interesting gore
can travel the time stream thanks to
obtaining the blood of the time gods
this allows him to battle different
thor's all across the time stream which
makes score a pretty intimidating threat
for any number of thors to face in the
new film
according to deadline russell crowe's
involvement in thor love and thunder was
supposed to be a secret unfortunately
the actor was spotted out one too many
times on australia with several other
cast members and the cat was out of the
bag his inclusion in the film was
confirmed in march 2021 and his role was
later revealed by the actor himself
while chatting with an australian radio
show crow said he had to leave to head
to a studio now i'm gonna get on my
bicycle i'm gonna ride up to disney fox
studios and round about 9 15 i shall be
zeus and thor 4. it's my last day of
zeus in about like christian bale crow's
entrance into the mcu is preceded by
time working on a dc project the
oscar-winning actor played jor-el the
father of superman in 2013's man of
steel we're not sure how big of a role
zeus will play in thor love and thunder
but crowe certainly seems to enjoy
playing the character the actor changed
his twitter avatar shortly after the
film's first official trailer dropped
when the screenshot of him is zeus
this fourth floor solo movie isn't that
much of a solo affair like many mcu
sequels before it eleven thunder serves
as a super friend team up of sorts thor
love and thunder will feature a majority
of the guardians of the galaxy when we
last saw the team they were in the
benetar after the battle of earth and
avengers end game thor joined them on
board where he and star-lord argued over
who was in charge the asgardians of the
galaxy were born and for all we know
thor has been traveling across the
universe with his new pals in the
meantime based on what we see in the
trailer and teaser for the film it looks
like all the guardians are back except
for gamora the galaxy's deadliest
assassin is currently in hiding after
time traveling from 2014 to 2023 in
avengers end game that said don't expect
the guardians to take center stage and
thor love and thunder as it's suspected
they will play a role in just the first
act
another former thor and thor the dark
world star is returning after missing
thor ragnarok deadline broke the news of
jaime alexander's inclusion in thor love
and thunder in december 2020 revealing
that the actress was returning to the
franchise's lady sith while alexander
has been on a lengthy break from the mcu
she did return his sif in episode 4 of
loki when loki is forced to relive one
moment from his life over and over again
on a time loop alexander also voiced
lady siff in episodes 3 and 7 of the
disney plus series what if after episode
4 of loki aired alexander took to
instagram to proudly declare lady sip
was back adding that she was here to
stay of course whether lady sif will
actually stick around past thor love and
thunder remains to be seen
and that's not all in july 2021 matt
damon confirmed his own return to the
mcu during an appearance on the just
kegel show following up on a hilarious
scene from thor ragnarok in which he
played an actor portraying loki he'll be
joined by luke hemsworth as the actor
portraying thor turns out their one-off
cameo appearances in the third thor
movie won't be one-offs after all we had
we had a ball and so taika had us back
again to kind of to kind of run that
joke back and
and and upgrade it a little bit also
returning to sam neal who played actor
odin in thor ragnarok an unofficial thor
love and thunder twitter account not
endorsed by marvel studios has already
shared some leaked set photos which
showed the jurassic park actor in full
odin gear with these three stars
returning we suspect we'll get another
asgardian play this time perhaps about
the events of thor ragnarok i think they
sussed out because paparazzi took
pictures of us so that they sussed out
what we were doing if they're recounting
thor ragnarok that means they'd need a
hella while still unconfirmed it looks
like none other than melissa mccarthy
will be playing the role of hela's actor
the daily mail shared photos of the
actress on the thor love and thunder set
sporting a costume that looks an awful
lot like hellas these photos landed
three months after mccarthy and her
husband ben falcone shared a pretend
audition tape on instagram asking taika
ytt if they could be in thor love and
thunder
thunder
[Music]
naturally taika ytt is back in the
director's chair for thor love and
thunder the filmmaker became a household
name after revitalizing the thor
franchise with thor ragnarok in 2017 ytt
managed to bring color laughter and a
solid story to the asgardian world which
makes his return to thor 4 no surprise
ytt is approaching love and thunder
differently than ragnarok though when
catching up with entertainment weekly
the director admitted he didn't want to
make the same mcu film a second time the
filmmaker said ragnarok felt a bit like
a party it was quite festive this one is
still fun and it's got moments of being
over the top but thematically it's about
something a bit deeper than the last
film it's not a serious film and it's
not a drama but we do deal with ideas
that i think a lot of humans deal with
universal themes about love and loss and
our place in the world he also noted
that his experience with his first mcu
film allowed him to shoot thor love and
thunder in a much more efficient way the
whole thing's a mess taka ytt also
returns in the film as cork the lovable
cronin we met in sakhar and thor
ragnarok
some sort of protoplasm all the stuff
that's coming out of you or are they
eggs
looks like eggs the first thor love and
thunder teaser dropped in april 2022 and
briefly touched on what's been going on
with thor's since we last saw him we got
a brief shot of bro thor with his
massive beer belly exercising with
chains while sporting a strongest
avengers trucker hat it looks like he
sheds the weight with ease as the rest
of the teaser shows him in tip-top shape
the guardians of the galaxy are featured
heavily in the teaser with star-lord
seemingly annoyed with his new friend
thor sports some ravager-looking clothes
and bids the guardians farewell as they
fly through a portal resembling one like
the space jump scene from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2. the teaser hints that
thor love and thunder will see thor on
an emotional journey as he tries to find
out who he is and what his purpose is in
this universe it looks like most of the
characters are on a path to
self-discovery including valkyrie who
seems rather bored with her leadership
role in new asgard the peaceful vibes of
the teaser disrupted at the end when
jane foster claims mjolnir and we get
our first look at mighty thor before the
clip abruptly ends
a month later thor love and thunder got
its first full trailer with 45 seconds
more of content there was a lot to
unpack while the teaser was light and
airy the trailer was a tad darker as it
gave us the first look at christian
bale's menacing villain gore the
godbutcher clearly this guy has a grudge
but all we know from what we're shown is
that he's creepy has a grudge and looks
like he'll be a worthy adversary to thor
also stealing the show in the trailer is
jane foster who we only see in mighty
thor gear and wielding mjolnir thor is
totally shocked to see his ex-girlfriend
show up out of nowhere let alone holding
his beloved hammer and it's clear there
are still feelings between the two
valkyrie picks up on this and questions
thor about what's going on between them
jane's mighty thor has also shown
summoning lightning in a mysterious dark
hall or cave surrounded by gold statues
some of which appear to represent
important characters from marvel comics
such as the living tribunal the watcher
infinity and death additionally the
trailer takes us to olympus where we see
russell crowe zeus for the first time
surrounded by women the god has thor
chained to the floor and strips off all
of his clothes causing an astounding
number of people around zeus to faint
there was also a look at jane competing
in some kind of battle on olympus
promising both comedy and action in this
particular hall of the gods
during the thor love and thunder panel
at san diego comic con in 2019 taika ytt
revealed that the new movie is inspired
by the mighty thor comic story line from
2015. written by jason aaron the story
follows jane foster as she becomes the
goddess of thunder after wielding
mjolnir tragically jane also has breast
cancer at this time and every time she
holds a hammer and transforms the
chemotherapy is eradicated from her body
however mjolnir will not eliminate the
cancer from her system meaning she
significantly risks death by continuing
to wield the hammer despite knowing that
her heroism could lead to her death jane
transforms into the goddess of thunder
one too many times and she ultimately
dies after defeating asgardian threat
mangog however after her death jane
refuses to go through the gates of
valhalla and is resurrected by odin she
returns to earth then her cancer
eventually goes into remission could
this mean a surprise appearance by
anthony hopkins odin might be gone in
the mcu but if he meets jane at the
gates of valhalla anything is possible
jane's cancer storyline may have been
confirmed for thor love and thunder
thanks to the description of a replica
thor helmet that's part of the official
merchandise for the film the direct
picked up on this subtle leak as the
helmet's description reads suffering
from cancer astrophysicist and thor's
ex-girlfriend jane foster visited new
asgard and her life was changed forever
the marvel cinematic universe timeline
it's a fickle little sucker that is more
confusing now than it's ever been but
whenever a new mcu project comes around
we have to figure out where we're
supposed to jam it in thanks to the time
jumping avengers end game the actual
earth that we live on doesn't quite
match up with the date in the mcu as we
resign in 2022 earth's mightiest heroes
are living somewhere in 2024 or 2025
however it might be easier to pin thor
love and thunder on the timeline based
on what we see in the trailer thanks to
the appearance of the guardians of the
galaxy we can assume thor love and
thunder takes place shortly after the
events of avengers end game when thor
left earth then the fledgling new asgard
to go on an adventure with the space
faring team a lot of phase 4 mcu films
happen simultaneously so thor love and
thunder could very well be occurring
during the same time as films like
chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
or eternals
being an mcu movie thor love and thunder
comes with dime a dozen fan theories and
rumors since a project was announced
there has been much speculation about
who might be popping up in the film
cameos in the mcu are extremely hard to
keep a secret these days so the powers
that be can pull off a shocking cameo or
hats are off to them perhaps the biggest
rumored cameo is out of ryan gosling who
some believe is joining the mcu based on
one lunch gosselin and taika white tt
were spotted having together before
filming began on thor love and thunder
gossip site just jared shared photos of
the duo together in august 2019 and fans
began speculating who he might play on
reddit beta ray bill's name seems to
keep popping up all via fan theory but
it's also possible gosling isn't in this
at all inverse reported on some rumors
which they admitted were sketchy that
suggest jeff goldblum will reprise his
role as the grandmaster and rachel house
will also be back as topaz also possibly
appearing is teeny tiny throgg aka thor
but a frog we got a glimpse of the
amphibian and loki episode 5 which was
actually a surprise chris hemsworth
cameo
speaking of loki what about tom
hiddleston we haven't heard anything
official even though he seems to be dead
in the timeline thor love and thunder
takes place and you can't count out the
god of mischief after all there are so
many of them
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one